bibbidi-bobbidi-boo okay good morning
everybody
look at this hair I look like a
disgusting [ __ ] another workout I just
got back from the gym working out with
Khalif and you guys know I've been on
this funny fanfic writing to be honest
with you the workouts have been
absolutely terrible terrible meaning
good but I think one of the hardest
things that's happening right now is
that you know I am losing weight but
it's not I guess it's not as like fast
or gratuitous as I want it to be so when
I don't see the numbers change it starts
to affect me mentally but I just have to
believe in the program and believe that
the people that are helping me on there
know what they're doing so I mean I feel
like I look better I'm not sure what do
you think Hey what today is gonna be
interesting I'm gonna be meeting up my
good friend justin chon you probably
seen justin chon and a lot of stuff like
on film
you yes you could say lightweight he's
probably one of my acting mentors like
when it comes to me wanting to be an
actor or even the stuff that I put out
on YouTube that's very film related he's
one of my inspiration she's somebody
that helps me out a lot it kind of gets
me into a mentality where I take my my
sketches at my heart a lot more
seriously
I'm your hair the [ __ ] you gotta fight
with the weed whacker and I think he's
been in the air for about a couple of
weeks and he's back in town so we're
gonna meet up talk say what's up and
catch up they don't use pasteurized milk
you got to always drink bottled water
and do a lot of weight because well
that's funny yeah I'll try to get some
of that dude your brains out
what's it when you go in these shows
like what are they expect you do
I mean it's stand-up essentially you
know Pinelli I think it's like my main
goal is like stand-up and their
motivation
speaking because I want them to like you
know I think with a lot of juice no know
what they're doing but like essentially
though they know you from YouTube though
yeah not neither stand back
well no I mean just because I used to do
stand-up a lot and then
but I still have like a skill set yeah
yeah no no I don't I don't doubt that
but like they're booking from YouTube
though that they saw you on YouTube
never yeah well the book me from YouTube
but they're getting me therefore like to
stand up in the motivation bar I mean
you know what I do feel though I feel
like Hollywood right now is like the at
a college you'd be like the fresh uh-huh
it's like a cool kids right and YouTube
and my Netflix still kind of Amazon
they're still like for the book club the
Chess Club but those nerds are the ones
that end up doing the coolest [ __ ] yeah
I didn't want you to be a platform where
I stayed to be a stepping-stone for
something else
you know but it seems like it's going
backwards I feel like everybody's going
back to here versus other people
pointing there because they see the
opportunity here and they don't see the
growth that's happening there do you
feel that you should start a step
towards that like
take some acting classes
do some stuff that is I yeah gonna
cultivate that like I mean I'm not
against acting classes like I think my
acting classes are doping if you want to
be an actor you have to do it but versus
me you know doing what I do or what
other people do like like I'm busy I
have to run this company yeah I mean I
that I do my stuff up we have like just
clean news that we're doing and then on
top of that we have shows like I feel
like a lot of actors do you know they
have a part-time job with anyway but you
you just told me that you just
specifically said that you do want to
get to sort of like what I'm doing in
terms of mainstream media
but then there needs to be certain steps
take tape to start moving that direction
anything well yeah well I don't think
I'm not doing that I like I'm not I'm
not like knocking on a [ __ ] acting
classes like I do eventually want to do
that but you know when it's the [ __ ]
time that is scheduled to do it I mean
if you really want it I feel like that's
what I mean I think that just you just
gotta always move in the right direction
of where you want to be you know if dad
is saying goal I mean if you want to
stay in YouTube that's cool yeah I get
that
like there's nothing wrong with that but
if you you told me specifically that you
want to do that to start doing more like
you know traditional media
anything something needs to happen
towards
but I think I every somebody no I'm I'm
not not doing anything like I'm I've
created like these short films on my
channels they have got millions of hits
I mean that's like [ __ ] that people on
TV would love to get you know yeah and
that's something I've produced with my
own money my own talent I wrote myself
which you know most people kennyman I
mean how many actors do you know can
even [ __ ] right to save their [ __ ]
lives they have the acting classes
that's great but if you put me into an
audition with these kids identity I'll
smash them off the [ __ ] water
you know that's how you than a million
in smash from out the water you don't
you know I got opportunities you know
and it just didn't work out I mean I
can't tell if you know anybody right now
about them but you know I decided to
keep my youtube than my integrity on my
channel versus you know giving myself to
a network you know is I want to create
opportunities for myself that works but
I like that that's like you know what it
could of you're saying like you can't
tell anybody about it but like the
reality of the situation is
it doesn't exist
yeah
that's that's what I feel I mean
it just doesn't exist until it does
exist and then you can
okay might as well just not say anything
well I mean that's why I haven't told
any about those anybody about those
projects no because I didn't I don't
have it now you know and I chose to do
like for example there was a TV show
that I was supposed to be on but I chose
to develop just to be news instead
epitaxy and that was a you know a choice
that I tell you but see that doesn't
make sense to me man because you're
saying that you want to get from A to B
why would you take the detour because a
has an opportunity to become B okay I
can see that cuz just kidding News
essentially in my personal opinion has
an opportunity to be doing an amazing TV
show that we can do through our own you
know what I mean and I'm down with that
you know so like I'm trying to take that
cleaners platform to you know I'm at the
end of the day what do actors do like
actors want to become actors and then
they become creators well I'm a creator
first that I'm trying to go into acting
yeah you know so it's just that my plan
is starting the other way around course
the other people's end goals you know
what I mean like Ben Affleck Ben Affleck
wasn't active first and it became a
writer in our director you know and I
don't maybe I have a twisted but in the
platform step now
you know just like for your case like
you're trying to become a creator oh
yeah I'm a bit on your own channel yeah
absolutely yeah yeah yeah I mean but the
same can go for you too I mean you've
said you wanted to make these like short
films on your channel you went to
vlogging because we were the easier
route I mean I could tell you the same
thing you have the means to make great
film projects but you know the person
that hinders for you from doing is
yourself you know there's something
you're stuck doing these lifelong don't
you call films which really harm films
you know like if you wanted to do a film
you could do it but you know when you
went to this thing instead that's true
as chairman
better I enjoy this I really like it
yeah
I mean I guess tit for tat
everyone has their own
kool-aid again right yeah sup y'all so
every now and then Khalif like he runs
lines before the script that he gets cuz
you know Cleve is an actor but I'm here
to help him out so I I kind of like to
help him read the lines because it keeps
me sharp to it it's like a part of the
world that I want to be so you know I
helped him out memorize his lines it
kind of like get into character and on
my side I get to see a little bit to the
acting world as well as up there making
hell annoys [ __ ] cleaning his
room with a goddamn Bruma [ __ ] speak of
the devil so I'm working on this in
class cuz my cockney accent sucks might
go
cockney accent are [ __ ] hella hard -
damn there's like this like the cockney
axes the one that Michael Caine has
right Michael Payne
yeah you know when he first came to LA
like he noticed that on film and TV that
people were very still so what he would
do is that he was just stare at people
not blink cuz he thought that was
stillness anyways he just has a word
glaze he does that all the time in his
new movie youth he does that too in
Harvey Keitel he made a big deal about
the whole white Oscars thing - well he
was he was like talking about like
diversity and also the [ __ ] it's kind of
weird cuz he's an old white guy I
thought he was racist they were talking
about David Bowie how he was getting
into about the [ __ ] because his wife
his wife who David Bowie
oh he's no I heard his wife would bless
the hell no really David Bowie yeah
because they were talking about how
madly in love he is with his wife and
yeah I just saw a black woman - yeah
she's pretty as hell what I know that is
but what yeah that's his wife I didn't
know that black dude she looks young as
[ __ ] she's 60 years old dude you tell me
right now that's a [ __ ] 60 year old
woman that is not as a 60 year old woman
fussing gorgeous fire you know it's
funny like
today like I met up with Justin you know
like he's all about like that whole
[ __ ] you know the whole acting or that
you know like he's been vlogging a lot
lately didn't on his vlog and [ __ ] but I
swear to God every time I talk to that
full about [ __ ] acting I think he he
was just like say some kind of smartass
[ __ ] [ __ ] about what I do and that's
not crazy yeah I could tell like he like
tiptoes around kind of like like he
doesn't want to like quote-unquote hurt
my feelings but I think he mentioned
some [ __ ] about like is but what do you
really do there when you go to [ __ ]
shows his [ __ ] which is [ __ ] he's
kind of alluding to the fact that I'm
not really putting the work in for it
which is kind of stupid and it doesn't
really make sense for for in my personal
perspective like he knows what I do for
a living do the work that way is the
work you know saying like this days like
2016 like I saw its involved so much
well that's what I'm saying - because
social media you know has changed up the
game and we all know that Hollywood has
lost a lot of money in terms of movies
and that I'll be looking for creators
like me to put it on a [ __ ] media
platform we said the [ __ ] make sense
was kind of makes him a hypocrite
because he's the one trying to go onto
YouTube right now you know like the way
Justin talks like he has like that way
of like saying something under his
breath so I don't know well I haven't
seen him a long time because he went to
India he came back and I mean you know
Justin I really closer he go back so
he's back
so my [ __ ] duty told me he was
gonna call me because I've been trying
to like find like representation because
it's so [ __ ] hard to find an agent or
a manager and so like I'm taking these
classes like these branding classes to
help you find your essence and so
reaching out to him to get his
perspective always wanted to do that but
I reach out so he's like doesn't respond
or like he's in India
what's your respect but which is you
know understandable book I mean she hit
her brother up like I'm trying to get
some advice from somebody well that's
why I'm talking about - like so yes it
hit me up in a while and that's why I
wanted to kick it with him because you
know he has me up when it when he comes
back immediately I don't know he did
that to you but he came up and then you
know we were talking about what he was
doing and [ __ ]
I don't know man like you just you know
way to [ __ ] pissing me off though
that's just but you're not sure if he
really means it like I think cuz you
guys are so headstrong yeah that's you
guys would it tiptoe
like there is no [ __ ] tiptoeing
there's like stray like [ __ ] two Rams
hitting each other and I think it's
because to like I do look up to him so
you know he's like slightly like
lightweight like my acting mentor
because he's the one who actually even
got me to to really focus on the acting
in my sketches you know to really kind
of set my [ __ ] apart from everybody else
of stuff which I'd really do appreciate
but I don't know if it's the way that he
goes about saying [ __ ] I don't know if
that makes me a [ __ ] because I wanted
to say it nicer know that you're like
talking about and I'm like thinking
about the times I've spoken so welcome
once I think sometimes you kind of I
think were pretty good at picking up a
non behavior stuff yeah so when he's
telling you something that he really
cares about and like and I know us that
what we talks to me like you kind of
like look away
yeah because he doesn't really care I'm
out okay now I know now that I haven't
thought about it but yeah but he lives
away because he wants to save some some
other [ __ ] but he's like trying to be
like really nice about it
and I don't you know he knows me like
you don't have to be [ __ ] nice about
that [ __ ] like if you want to say
something just say something and I think
like we've been friends now for like
four or five years so if you got
something to say say what's on your mind
then we could talk it out like men and
then see what's up after but maybe he
feels like I can't take his criticism
which I could take I think it's pretty
viable that he can give me critique
because he is a successful actor and I
kind of want to be in his position so I
don't know man I just don't like it's
like when somebody attacks your art he
may not see it as art but then I see
this that's my [ __ ] work I mean what
else do I [ __ ] do yeah I can only
assume that he is like the best and yeah
I'm not gonna assume I know he has the
best intentions so you know so I just
guys see well you sound like recent
successes and you think that would make
him change a little bit I mean maybe
yeah maybe because he expects me to be
further than where I am and I'll give it
to him a little bit like I talked about
being an actor and I haven't really done
it I've been on the space for like four
or five years and a lot of the
opportunities I got was because of my
youtube though it's not like I haven't
done auditioning before you know and I
thought but the medium has changed so
much that it's like you always read
about it on these
deadlines or they're all reported like
yeah like people are networks are going
to YouTube you see where the audience is
and you have like over a million
subscribers I'm saying so you've created
something that a million people are
interested in like these are numbers you
know I'm saying like I can't just see
how just someone think that would be not
worthy of it being work at the end of
the day I almost say best intentions but
if he says one more [ __ ] thing I'm
gonna guess the [ __ ] knows he knows
what's up cuz he I mean he was a part in
that conversation so he knows what the
[ __ ] he said yeah so this is a part of
the video if he doesn't [ __ ] like it
then he should change how the [ __ ] he
talks to me that's it but right now like
I told you I'm giving him the [ __ ]
benefit benefit of the doubt yeah so I'm
thinking that he is saying stuff to
better me as a person I'm saying it on
camera just and hopefully he'll see
through the whole other's video and
he'll realize I'm not just talking [ __ ]
I'm saying he has the best intentions
and if he knows that that he or he knows
where he's coming from and he won't have
a [ __ ] problem the video and if he
wants me to take it down well [ __ ]
I'm still not gonna tell ya these are
real-life ones like I mean you know true
cuz people like what more like you we
see the comments from all these people
on like Instagram or YouTube like yo
show me what you're eating or show me
what like your print like people are
prying to personal stuff where is like
yo that's what you would but that's the
[ __ ] though like people don't get it
like okay like you you want [ __ ] life
vlogs I mean this is the [ __ ] that I go
through it's not always jokes it's not
always happy and it gets [ __ ] wrong
between friends this isn't be like some
real [ __ ] like yeah yeah this is some
[ __ ] okay I'm gonna feel like either
you're like Road rules they're like
Justin's like real world and I'm gonna
have to like get between that [ __ ] cuz
you guys gonna eventually it's that
point oh yeah they're strong
personalities man I don't think you are